[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
hôpital le Sénat veut un nombre minimum
de soignants par patient
à l'heure où l'hôpital souffre de départ
massif de soignants comment améliorer à
la fois la qualité des soins et les
conditions d'exercice des soignants
mercredi 1er février 2023 le Sénat a
adopté la proposition de loi relative à
l'instauration d'un nombre minimum de
soignants par patient hospitalisé déposé
par le sénateur Bernard gommier elle
traduit en acte une préconisation de la
commission d'enquête sénatoriale sur
l'hôpital qui s'inspire du succès des
expériences analogue menées en
Californie et dans l'État du Queensland
en Australie par cette proposition de
loi le Sénat entend ainsi diminuer la
charge des soignants aujourd'hui épuisés
et restaurer des conditions d'exercices
décentes pour les personnels
hospitaliers
concrètement chaque spécialité et chaque
type d'activité se verraient attribuer
un ratio minimal de soignants par lit
ouvert ou par nombre de passages pour
les activités ambulatoire les ratios
tiendraient compte de la charge de soins
liés à l'activité il pourrait être
modulé en fonction de la taille et de la
spécialisation des établissements en cas
de dépassement pendant une durée
supérieure à 3 jours un mécanisme
d'alerte a été prévu à l'initiative de
la rapporteur Laurence Rossignol le chef
d'établissement serait alors tenu
d'informer le directeur général de
l'agence régionale de santé
pour donner le temps au secteur
hospitalier d'amorcer ce tournant le
Sénat prévoit une mise en oeuvre
progressive du nouveau dispositif d'ici
2027 le texte est désormais transmis à
l'Assemblée nationale
pour en savoir plus consultez le site du
Sénat
[Musique]